well there are a lot of emotional highs
and lows in this business I mean you
could be doing one thing one day and
then the rug gets pulled out from under
you and there is a lot riding on you so
how do you handle when something is not
going right I mean believe me we all
have freaked out so Brett what what
would you do to kind of center yourself
or you just let it all fly yeah I don't
know i mean it's it's funny because you
know those moments I kind of live for
those moments where you have two feet
firmly and right you know and you can
you can fight you know flat out and
fight for something but it's so seldom
that isn't it it's like because so many
of the problems that you have you
probably need that person for something
else that you know I'm just saying it's
complicated especially with no money if
you have lots of money then you know you
hire who's best for the job if they suck
or if they you know do something wrong
you can fire them and hire someone else
in the independent world it's not that
easy it's like you know you got several
plates up in the air and you got no
fallback plan so very seldom do you get
to just freaked out and feel better
about it normally it's you got to put on
a face and go through the steps but
again it's about how important the final
project product is like you know when
shooting the movie we would always talk
about with me acting and directing and
everything and I had kind of his brain
trust of people including my DP and my
editor and my producers and you know we
had this rule that was like you know
there's no holds barred you got
something to say if you got a problem
with something you know you need to tell
me because I'm gonna be really upset if
we get through the day and there's a
problem that I didn't know it was a
problem you know that being said we had
to keep in mind the movies the most
important thing it's more important than
my ego or my feelings or anybody else's
ego we're feelings it's like the movie
is the most important thing getting a
good product out of this and it's still
that it's still my freaking out on you
know a distributor who isn't doing
things the way that I want or you know
graphics designer that isn't working out
the way I want
if it doesn't help the movie it just
helps me feel better about how the days
gone that make sense so there's lots of
hemming and hawing when I'm much more of
a shoot from the hip kind of guy and
it's it suits me better to be able to do
that but I feel like so seldom can you
you